ego is selfishness over solidarity power
without morals that's what I'll be
discussing today with half greed mukla
one of Germany's best-known political
scientists welcome to the program good
to have you with us too for the DW
interview my name is thomas pan mr.
Mandela you wrote a dissertation on
niccolò machiavelli and a lexicon on the
renaissance how did that come about do
you just love Italy well I certainly got
to know Italy better through my
dissertation and I came to love it too I
really appreciated the somewhat
different way of life one two and
niccolo machiavelli sharp mind the way
he fought was very challenging to me but
at the same time a pleasant companion to
my own thinking light understandings and
a different way of life it starts with a
climate it's not advisable to work
through the middle of the day at least
not in summer so you develop a certain
ease a more relaxed attitude to time
unless you have an air-conditioned
workspace that's the modern Italy as
opposed to the traditional Italy wrote
the Renaissance lexicon that I mentioned
together with your wife living and
working together can sometimes be
challenging was it more fun than working
your case that's alright I in fact I
know how I was followed along in the
script it was certainly challenging and
there are many such projects where
marriage has not survived that kind of
collaboration my wife is a literary and
cultural scholar in the wider sense
I don't think weeders would be able to
tell which of us wrote which chapters if
you try to guess going by our professor
you come up with the wrong answer often
get orphaned ahead salvation that
diversity here on there's less minimum
for returning to Machiavelli his theory
of divide and rule and the idea that the
end justifies the means
appears to be very much in evidence
right now when we look at Russia and
Turkey would you say that's the case
yeah what does in fact that's an
oversimplification
that's base to a certain extent on the
presumption that Machiavelli was
Machiavellian that's probably as
simplistic as the idea that Marx was a
Marxist Marx said expressly I am NOT a
Marxist we don't have a statement like
that from Machiavelli but then while he
was alive there was no established line
of thinking known as Machiavellianism
certainly one of Machiavelli's central
ideas was that one should focus on the
underlying interests involved and on
geographical constellations and not so
much on the romanticism of talk about
values he never put it that way
but that was basically what he was
saying and the reason is because behind
all the talk about values there are
always interests at stake and those who
want to know how things will turn out in
a serious situation and how those
involved will decide should look more at
the situation and the interests involved
and less at what values of being
espoused and be open if I could endure
to be a DES that's what I'm referring to
that Western values in particular human
rights play a secondary role both in
Putin's Russia and air diwan's Turkey
and when it comes to the refugee issue
Europe is especially dependent on both
of these countries so how is it that
Europe is now at the mercy of others I'd
say the divide in values goes right
through Europe Asia grad States the
Czech Republic Hungary Poland and
Slovakia have somewhat different ideas
those universal values are subject to
national interests and national value
systems whereas in Germany or let's be
generous and say in the western and
northern he you states perhaps the
opposite is true that has nothing to do
with core values but more because those
countries are much more integrated into
the global framework so that
universalism and globality tend to meet
and complement each other when you talk
about Turkey and Russia they're
influenced by geographical
constellations which have come into play
because the international community has
waited too long on the Syria question
not to put too fine a point on it there
were reasons to wait we don't know who's
our ally we don't know what our goal
would be if we intervened but this
waiting has caused these two former
empires Russia which once ruled as
Tsarist Russia and also as the Soviet
Union and Turkey with its Ottoman Empire
to develop something akin to neo
Imperial dreams
what's my initial hike so it must be neo
Emperor latina of columns in vision and
Angela Merkel nationalized the refugee
crisis by opening Germany's borders for
migrants now she wants to European eyes
the crisis was that a mistake I don't
think you can describe it like that
opening the borders back then in late
August early September was basically a
step that made the territory of Germany
available as an overflow for a problem
that had built up in the Balkans
I blame does he often Boca understood if
you imagine what would have happened if
Germany hadn't taken in the refugees who
had broken out in Hungary and ran onto
the motorway with the resulting
repercussions you could have probably
written off the entire stabilization
strategy for the Balkans he dispelled
calm it didn't translate - curtain it
when the crisis arose in Hungary
shouldn't Angela Merkel had gone to
Brussels
discussed this problem in European terms
and put pressure on the other Europeans
instead of bringing the refugees to
Germany in a forum in the retrospective
in hindsight you might come to the
conclusion that that would have been the
better step in tactical terms the
question is how long would it have taken
for this step to be successful the
problem at the time was to act under
time pressure acting under time pressure
is the nature of politics so yes it
would have been wiser to keep the
Hungarians hanging for a while actually
all of the Vichy grad group who are now
causing this stress in the hope that
some refugees would eventually go to
Poland and bring about a solution that
way you could say that at the time
Germany's politicians were too hasty and
too mindful that no damage be done to
Europe there's a hope and a pathetic
thought okay I mean what we know now you
could say they should have demonstrated
more calm and composure they could have
played for time and so to speak only
helped when the others were just short
of drowning but you really can't blame
Angela Merkel now for not having done
that guitar note the torture in Germany
every refugee has the right to have
their case decided in the courts do you
think Germany's asylum law might have to
be reformed or even scrapped to end this
crisis fancy pants by Germany basically
has two options either create a proper
immigration law and immigration policy
and thereby relieve the pressure on the
individualized Asylum system and leave
that for the kind of scenario for which
it was originally intended continue to
further restrict and modify the asylum
law what if it's yet that would probably
not be a good development then the only
guidelines would be the terms of the
refugee
invention of 1951 STM defendant hmm
Germany's asylum law is almost a sacred
institution especially for left-leaning
people you were once a young socialist
to yourself I'll bet you would have
sharply criticized any changes oh I
don't know I mean I was also involved in
local politics that means I was in the
fortunate position of being able to
observe the consequences of my political
actions relatively quickly of course
there are differing perceptions here
those who are relatively close to the
problems who were worried about the
logistics of how to house everyone the
mayors and the district administrators
they will have a different perspective
than those who worry about preserving
social democratic tradition or the
tradition of liberalism or whatever with
all the talk about Greece the special
status for Britain and the refugee
crisis will the EU survive 2016 I can
imagine it's surviving but not in its
current form if it does survive then
only because it's entered into a process
of transformation isn't you've been
called a one-man think tank with a
wealth of knowledge as a political
scientist have you never been tempted to
go into politics yourself to change
things you have hinted at that a CAPTA I
was involved in politics at the local
level until 1985 I enjoyed it and at the
time I withdrew from it because of the
birth of our daughter
I basically been doing it for 12 years
that's quite a lot for a political
scientist so I know that area I'm
researching fairly well besides research
is incredibly sweet you can scarcely
imagine their knowledge do you hope to
pass on to your children
mmm cool a bottle
sober reflection toughness and a good
work ethic and also a basic sense of
optimism that boils down to there are
always decisions and courses of action
you can take you must find them and
never sink into melancholy thus which
brings us to the point in the interview
where we asked you to finish three
sentences for us Europe is in a
desperate State but I still hope for
Tots team does that it finds the
strength to return to orderly policies
and structures - it sort of it I've
written many books and I'm often on TV
the jealousy of some of my colleagues is
annoying
then if I'd lived in the Renaissance I
would have I really like to be someone
like niccolò machiavelli half-read
Moncler thank you
gladly